- All right, time's
almost up on this hour,
but first I wanna share
one more uplifting story.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
So, I've always been an outdoor girl.
I grew up that way,
but the same can't be said
for lots of kids who
grew up in big cities.
That's why a Charlotte man is
taking dozens of kids in his
community under his wing,
teaching them the skills
and joys of camping,
which is so cool.
From Camping with Cradle,
let's welcome Keith Cradle
watching on WCCB Charlotte CW.
What's up, man?
(audience cheering)
- Hey, Kelly, how are you doing?
- I am doing so well.
So, why did you wanna do this?
- Well, I just love the outdoors,
and I know you do too,
but so many kids here in Charlotte
just don't have that opportunity
and so we created Camping with Cradle
to provide that outlet and an opportunity
to get them backpacking,
camping, and hiking.
I previously worked
for the Mecklenburg
County Sheriff's Office
where I was director of youth programming,
and so I was working to
help rehabilitate kids,
and the sheriff said,
"Hey, what's one thing
that you'd love to do
that we haven't?"
It was Camping 101.
It grew from there.
And to date, we've taken 60 kids out
camping and backpacking,
and really diversifying the outdoors,
and letting them know that
they belong in those spaces.
- Absolutely, it's so therapeutic as well
just to get outdoors
and be, like, one with nature,
at the risk of sounding like a hippie,
but, like, it is.
It's a beautiful thing
just to get outdoors
and outside of a city,
and just have quiet, and
be still, and enjoy nature.
It's really cool what you're doing.
So they're able to experience
this free of charge,
which is the coolest part, right?
- That's the whole reason why we do it.
We want to bridge that gap
when it comes to access and
inclusion in the outdoors.
And so, all the outings are free,
and for kids that go backpacking with us,
they have an opportunity
to keep that gear,
so they don't have to go
out and pay for it later on.
We teach them about outdoor safety,
of course, plant life,
but no matter what,
they always seem to find the poison ivy.
And then they also get journals as well,
so they can document that experience,
and we talk about that around the fire.
And, once again, it's
just a great opportunity
for them to recreate
and not have those phones for a few days.
- Absolutely, thank you so much, Keith.
This is so cool, what you're doing.
- Thank you.
- I'm liking your post
right now, man.
(audience cheering)
- [Keith] Thank you.
- Well, that's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, sir.
So they're gonna be writing
Camping with Cradle a check
for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Oh, wow, thank you.
- Absolutely, man.
Thank you so much,
and thank you to all our guests this hour,
Ken Jeong, Charlie Day, Guy Branum,
Alex Cooper, and Corey.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.